you know the strangest thing you can ask
someone right now is what are you up to
or what have you been up to have you
have you had someone to ask you that yet
hey man what are you up to
why what am I'm up to nothing I'm up to
nothing where there's nothing to do wha
hey man what you been doing nothing
Hey hey buddy I know nothing do do you
understand
I you know I I've realized one of my
buddies is a psycho path or psycho
whatever it is psychopath he's like hey
man what do you been doing huh oh me oh
yeah man I just been you know I just
travel we went to the waterslide last
weekend and um you know we went to
DiMaggio's you know that restaurant
nothing I've been doing nothing the same
thing that everybody has been doing no
matter who you are right now you're
doing I don't care if you are Walter
Disney you're doing nothing even people
that are smoking DMT right now no matter
how hard a hit they take nothing happens
because there's nothing to do hey man
what you been up to nothing
nothing absolutely nothing there's
nothing to do III think like there's
nothing I mean I have been people like
what do you been doing well honestly
what I've been doing usual stuff I do
really try not to masturbate or do
self-pleasure do self bust I have been I
have learned I I've learned that I can
cook and then I've learned that I don't
know any good recipes that's what I
learned I learned like okay I'm I'm
willing to cook like I find myself just
making something that's around my
apartment like oh okay
I'll have a little bit of lettuce and
oatmeal
oh there could be something you know I
found myself
mixing oh yeah yeah I'll have a pop-tart
and I'll have you know I have a pop-tart
and I'll have two orange halves or
orange you know just like wild mixes
okay I'll have a little you know some
cuts of um
London broil and uh and you know and
maybe for baby snicker and that's dinner
just the two connect like things that
connect there that the the it doesn't
matter anymore it you you know before
corvid it was like the the the
afternoons connected to the lunchtime
the evenings connected to the dinner but
now we don't matter the breakfast is
connected to the midnight snack
it don't matter o rise and shine you
know I got half a bag of Cool Ranch
Doritos and um and you know a third of a
cup of uh you know baby marshmallows for
you and don't forget to have don't
forget to squeeze uh you know a chunk of
lime in your mouth and and that's it
it's just you know the there's the I'm
just saying that you can have whatever
you want right now and it can be a meal
you don't even have to mix things like
before pre pre corvid you had to mix
stuff oh you want to make a cake you
need to get an egg do an egg in a bucket
do a flour do some milk or some leche
some Mexican milk and do it like that
and do it and mix it up and throw some
sprinkles in it and put I on doing of it
and then to do damn you got a cake you
got a birthday you got to come play on
yose you know circle a cake
but now don't matter you wanna [ __ ]
crack an egg in your mouth you want to
take half a dram of water a little bit
of milk eat a quarter stick of butter
you know high two packets of um sugar
under your tongue of sugar in the raw
BAM son you know you've had some cake
there's just the the the template is
kind of blown out
oh it's lunch time why don't you have a
freaking porterhouse steak with a
Chobani yogurt
why don't you do you want to peel it a
little do a Chobani daddy do that little
you know how to [ __ ] how to half a
gram of yogurt in your little cousins
jaw and then you know and then beat his
little ass if you have to sorry you know
let him you know don't just hit him like
in the back and like in the fat areas
don't hit him anywhere ever it's gonna
hurt him what's going on I don't know I
don't I don't it's the dumbest what's
going on
not a Spanish nothing nothing is going
on I've been at home I don't even know
it's out it's nice to not have to set
your alarm clock didn't I know some of
you have children you can't relate to it
but it's nice to not have to set your
alarm you know I don't need an alarm for
anything right now
I don't need I don't it doesn't would if
it's it doesn't matter if it's 11:50
p.m. or 4:00 a.m. I can watch another
episode of shits Creek and then go back
to bed doesn't matter
matter if it does it does it nothing
matters nothing man
nothing nothing I'm just trapped playing
with the Devils that are inside of me
that's what I'm doing most of the
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one